les souvenirs sont fragiles je veux
qu'on dessine la bonne personne on a
juste besoin d'assez détails pour qu'il
puisse être identifié par l'une de ses
connaissances si marche pas personne ne
le connaît
[Musique]
j'ai appris ce matin que les ouvriers
ont découvert le cadavre d'une jeune
femme qui s'appelle giulia
ya six ans j'ai été découpée comme elle
celui qui a fait ça à giulia a essayé de
faire la même chose
si tu essaies tu devenir journaliste
c'est ça que tu dois raconter
après ce qu'il a fait les choses ne sont
plus comme elle devrait être
ça commence avec des petites choses
et après c'est des grandes choses
et personnes se souvient que c'était
différent
il ya plusieurs femmes qui ont été
assassinés sur plusieurs dizaines
d'années
ce lien qui existe entre elle séduit y
en aura d'autres
je sais pas comment il fait mais il me
surveille et puis que c'est petit
il est tout le monde et les personnes
il traverse deux tours
pourquoi vous faites ça commence à
bouger que ça
quelque chose qui n'est pas encore
arrivé peut arriver à un vêtement
on est tous connectés
des choses changent pour moi d'une
seconde à l'autre
et ensuite ça arrive encore et encore
[Musique]
je te ferai pas le cas
comment il s'appelle
qui est l'homme qui vous rend visite